i want to talk about indian matchmaking
i love did you watch it with her
i don't know much about it please inform
me well maybe if you spend some time
with kaleila at night all right you know
what
all right okay i you know what you guys
could have some shared interest oh okay
christine okay rebuttal can i have a
robot defensive
cuddly baby i love to cuddle i'm a
cuddler too come on over
and i beg tom's not a cuddler but can
you please
all i want is for you to spoon me for 15
years i beg
beg and i force him to do it i'm hot i'm
hot
i'm like okay
this is what i want to say okay
during this pandemic yeah there's not
much to do
right a lot of dreams are on hold
right we are very a very mindful
household
should we have not gone to the grocery
store one time no
that's reasonable okay we haven't done
anything so her and i
are together in this house together
right right 24 7.
all right i have a video game addiction
i already told you
but secondly at nights my brother if you
know my brother steve
my brother steve doesn't wake up until
what time you think
8 p.m oh wow what yeah nocturnal now
he's a vampire
right so he'll wake up at 8pm drink two
red bulls and he's ready to go
i haven't seen him physically okay
that's your choice though you can
okay i just okay all right so then
at nights we play war zone together
right so he's i can hear him we talk
about our days
right we giggle laugh it's almost as if
we're calling each other
but we play for hours oh my god oh my
god what she's doing the technique like
i would be
so upset i i'm
so bad would you be so would you be so
dry my [ __ ]
would be so dry
oh my god what are you doing right now
like i put elmer's glue in it like all
right
well then what do you want me to do then
i wouldn't do it then
well do you guys okay how often do you
do your how often do you interact with
each other
truly throughout the day like meaningful
interest well now i
have to basically force him into
our nights together because that's the
one thing that we've talked about in
therapy i mean i don't care that we're
that i don't see you during the day but
i love a good wine down yeah with my
that's all i want and a partner is
someone to end my day with
i agreed why else are you you in it yeah
so maybe maybe you go to bed classic
rebuttal
yep come on go keep going maybe could
you set some time aside for kaleidos
maybe have a nice meal together you
drink your wine she goes to bed before
you ellie tv show's over here
[Laughter]
listen relax guys relax i'm not falling
for this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] okay
it's [ __ ] i had you [ __ ] none of
you guys are defending me by the way
right
right you play the game as well you
don't want anyone to have like a dry
[ __ ]
yeah i'll [ __ ] you all right now listen
all right
let's go back to indian summer go ahead
indian summer time tell me about the
show is it fun what about kissing booth
too
have you watched i got one i haven't but
i heard it was better than kissing booth
the first one wow i love him i saw him
at um
mendocino farms really my niece united
because she's obsessed with
what doesn't mean what is the show for
people it's not a show it's a teenage
movie
it's a teenager it's what everyone's all
the cool people are watching
well you and i need to start interacting
more at night because i watch a lot of
shows
but i go to bed by 9 30. oh and then i'm
up at 6 00 a.m with kids so yeah we're
on a different day and that might be why
tom and i are a little more
regimented with our time because he
can't go down and like play video games
until four in the morning
do you feel as though you know how they
say um um
students do better when they're in
sports because they had their force to
manage their time do you feel as though
you are um better together now
because of having to um because of the
kids
yeah idle hands are the devil's
playground there we go
there we go idle hand let me write that
down idle hands is the devil's prick
prank
playground i think brody said that
that's just that brody said the same
thing yeah brody yeah stevens
i know i was hoping you weren't
referring to my love
yeah yeah it does it lends itself to
structure definitely
yeah you're right guys you know i if i
didn't you know
if i didn't play video games all day
long um maybe
i could sell more tv shows oh my gosh
and be on tv more
in a pandemic and uh maybe have three
hit podcasts oh wow
yeah maybe he really does struggle with
um
for someone so sleepy and so lazy he
struggles with
you struggle with stillness isn't that a
weird oh
yeah no that's being afraid of your
feelings and stuff
i love it that's classic pile it on
oh boy but it's not all comedians there
we go
that's the magic there we go okay
nobody is i'll tell you why okay can i
just defend myself real quick
okay yeah let me just i feel i'm in the
middle of a corner
i love this way out feel free to stand
up too yeah we love this okay you love
this
this is like the best day of my life i
feel so hurt and validated
okay all right so here's a here it is
yeah
well okay because i too i was going
through strange behaviors i went through
a wig phase where i bought
so many wigs etsy i was buying jewelry
on etsy
i was like spiraling i was drinking and
then baking and then dead
do you not usually drink not like that
not like every night you know
and to my therapist and she's like well
yeah you know you're not feeling
the feelings and i'm like oh yeah i
forgot about those like i don't like
them
either so i get it
anyways but what were you saying about
him he wanted to defend himself first
oh i'm sorry defenders from our apparent
attacks okay
and i'm not this is not this is i'm not
um i don't like to reiterate
things and visit the past all right but
i need i feel like i'm a caged animal
and i need to fight my way out yes okay
so here we go here are the good assets
of me
yeah all right yeah and this is you have
so many but you're watching
thank you that's why i want to spend
time with you because she likes
i love you i love your company i want to
be with you okay
i love it thanks i enjoy it
thank you so much for saying it he hits
my heart
in such a spectacular way have you
enticed him with food because sometimes
that'll make tom talk to me also
i tried so in the beginning of core
that's exactly what i did
i'm sweating i bought every single
indulgent
food that he wanted same yeah but then
our therapist said
if that's what it's gonna take for you
to be around her your relationship's in
trouble
oh boy i was like oh [ __ ] okay he's like
her feelings and
her requests should be enough i said
uh i didn't think that didn't know
give me your hand but i still do bait
him with food yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah your hand okay
yeah every single relationship
i've ever been in and i've said this to
my brother i've said this internally
over and over again
there's a two-year window i know
when sorry go ahead why can i just
say it and then shake your head no no i
feel bad for your exes because they
didn't know that you had a two-year
window
okay my bad i'm opening a minute now
okay
all right that i had a two-year window
at the two-year point
i would somehow i would try different
techniques
right but i would somehow make them
leave
oh wow i i interes when i
in our old apartment i found a letter
that his ex wrote
to him like snail mail and it
broke my heart i honestly like i felt so
much for this girl like she was just so
blindsided
what what do you mean what was it about
it was like a breakup letter
yeah it was a breakup letter very
nervous and i think it said something
along the lines of
it was just really expressing how much
hurt she felt and he kind of just pushed
her out and then didn't want to speak to
her for a certain amount of time
but she was still really gracious about
it she was like you know thank you for
our time together
i don't know what i did wrong kind of
thing
but she didn't know about the two-year
window she did not know
all right so can we go back to
definitely defending myself yeah
thank you so much gilbert do it all
right get him right here
so i always had two a year in window
right yeah so when i met kalila
okay we met at a coffee shop people know
listening to the podcast how we met
right and when i met her
i had a sensation go over me and it was
a feeling
that i had never had before i maybe
never have
ever again right whereas the feeling was
i know this person oh that's cool okay
not
you know in this lifetime but there it
was a familiarity
is that how i said mm-hmm with her right
and i had a sense of dread as as long as
with
it and not a dread it was just more of a
oh this is this is this is the forever
thing
you know this is you know this is this
person that i'm meeting right now
right is somebody that i've never had
anyone check all the boxes for me
wow okay and when i'm with her
usually every girlfriend i've ever had
in the history of me having girlfriends
i can't sleep next to them i do sleep
right
i lived with one you know but every
night was a restless night of sleep
because there was just no comfort there
right with her
and i've always slept like a baby next
to her almost as if we're
one person okay when i look at her
i trust her god words bobby no i trust
her
implicitly right i've i've said that
i've had a resurgence in my career
there's no other girl
on this planet that would have done that
for me except for her
she did it all all right and i
she's one of my fav she is my favorite
person i've ever met in my whole life
she's my favorite person i've ever met
in my whole life i love her so [ __ ]
much
okay now i know my dad died in august
trying to
not cry i know making me cry no but i
know that my dad died i know my dad died
okay i know last in last august right i
have a lot of [ __ ] problems
i was molested i was beaten by my dad i
have all these
defense mechanisms right because i don't
want to feel
yeah you know i don't you know um i like
just
playing video games because i i it is i
escape
right and i don't do drink i don't do
drugs anymore i don't drink i'm sober
almost
10 months right and i'm proud of myself
and i have problems
right and i'm [ __ ] struggling with
these things
i really am i feel guilt and shame over
it over it
okay but my feelings for her is forever
and um i would never lie to her
i would never cheat on her i would never
do
anything outwardly to hurt her because
she's my favorite person of all time and
i've met many people
okay so you guys can rip on me all you
want
you can rip on me all you want right and
you can call me a piece of [ __ ] i'm a
bad guy
right now okay that's a defense [ __ ] you
okay
[ __ ] you all right [ __ ] both of you
wow that was like a few good men that
was that good that was [ __ ] good
yeah that was good that's a defense oh
you just wrote that on the spot that was
really good
but that's come with the heart right yes
yeah it comes from the heart
and you're you're right okay i'm not
proud of the fact that i play video
games all night long
all right but can i say something during
all the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that's going
on
my two friends are in trouble you know
yeah
people that i love like brothers
right are in trouble
right blm pandemic
right there's a lot going on in the
world right and i am just trying to
survive
and i want a little semblance of like i
don't want to
[ __ ] feel anything yeah i know and
and i'm addicted to it it's
it and when i'm playing war zone with my
buddies
very good on the war [ __ ] very season
five coming up right you're very good on
the battlefield
you as well thank you thanks for having
me back brother but um
you know i mean christina's dream i'm
trying to think but here's the i agree
with you we're all coping
like we're all just holding on to like
i don't know dude this week i'm really
into [ __ ] a t uh netflix
i'm into the indian matchmaker show it's
all i have man
you know finish i did and i'm so bummed
that there's no season two
there isn't season two with sema
honestly cherish every
episode oh i'm finished i i i
i i don't know i was really kind of um
annoyed with sema auntie
she's annoying but here's the deal
kalyla needs you too
that's her way of getting through this
is that she's
as if you didn't hear my beautiful
monologue give it again give the same
one one more time
it's as if you were even in the room
a piece of youtube is for her survival i
think you're essential to herself
and you have to kind of frame it in your
mind like this
i genuinely
enjoy your company and i want to be
around it
i want to be around your life i like you
for you i
i like you so much and i want to be with
you at night
very good kalila
i'm ready for your rebuttal you better
have a bottle to this she likes you
do you hear what she's saying yeah um
she'll do because i've been in
relationships where i'm like oh
get out of my face and i never feel that
way with him there's always
something like all our exchanges there's
always something to be had from it
whether
and i'm naturally not a sunny person i'm
kind of a
emo kind of sad depressive
say that again and he
he makes me giggle and i want to giggle
bingo
well then bobby how about can we have
two things can you have your time with
her at night and then is there a time
i'm sorry i'm sorry um can i just say
something